you can check them out as always on
Netflix is stand-up in a way a new
Netflix special that / is premiering for
streaming worldwide on Christmas Eve
stand up and away with Brian Regan good
to see you thank you Brian Regan it's
actually a series it's a four episode
series the each of them are about a half
an hour and it's called stand up and
away with Brian Regan okay
very good very happy about an executive
produced by Jerry Seinfeld yes which is
pretty darn cool isn't that I mean just
he could be the coolest guy on on planet
earth this is not felt I was so
fortunate that he wanted to do this and
we went in and pitched it to Netflix
which I just found the whole thing to be
absurd because I'm lucky enough to have
Jerry Seinfeld sitting next to me at the
pitch meeting and just the fact that
he's there means they're gonna do it
just me walking no matter what they
asked my answer just had to be that's
Jerry sighs how do you see the show
progressing that's Jerry Seinfeld so you
didn't even dress appropriately for the
meeting you just even have to care what
you look like I mean it was it was a big
deal and I was happy to have the
opportunity and it was just a cool
experience well I'll tell you one of
years ago I mean when I was on
SportsCenter so this had to have been
around 2000 2001 or something like that
I'm standing on the street corner in the
Upper West Side cuz I had a crashing pad
there to get out of Central Connecticut
when I want to had days off right so I'm
there on the Upper West Side and a
friend of mine is coming to pick me up
to go play golf so I'm standing on
corner of Columbus and like 70 something
with my bags my coat might my golf bag
on a street corner okay a big SUV pulls
up at the red light window rolls down
and it's Jerry Seinfeld leans out he
goes hey rich eyes and watch on
SportsCenter all the time and I'm like
Jerry Seinfeld had and he goes suit you
were there perfectly tailored they're
perfectly caught on like up Thanks at
which point he looks at me goes so
Columbus Avenue
yeah and I didn't even know what I said
like turns green light goes up zip here
it goes and wow that was one of the
greatest drive-bys I've had my entire
life I remember one time going uh I was
you know you out on the road you play a
city in the south and you play a city in
the north so I had my golf clubs with me
because I had chosen Florida but then
next week was New York City and it was
January and I had my golf clubs there's
like a foot and a half of snow yeah and
you know I'm in the elevator with the
bellman and I've got my cough clubs and
only New York dude bellman just you know
jab you go you're gonna get nine holes
in in Central Park this week you know I
mean you're from Florida correct yes
from originally yes all right which
means you had to have at least attempted
playing football right if you're in
Florida I played football in high school
okay our team just went to the state
championship and lost by two points
Machado what's uh Christopher Columbus
High School which you know named after
the director right named to the director
is that right that's right okay probably
that's the safer the safer answer now
okay of course named after the famous
story sir
and yeah so when we played other teams
it was very hard because it would put
banners up you know and they would say
things like Cinque Columbus mm and man
that those are probably the darkest the
darkest saddest moments of my life is
reading Cinque Columbus do you ever be
bad yeah yeah well I mean it unless
there was like a an English class it
would say goodbye Columbus right you
know what I'm saying true so I played at
Columbus yes then I played Heidelberg
College Heidelberg college's Division
three Northwest Ohio how'd you get how'd
you get there from South Florida
three of my high school football coaches
had migrated down from Heidelberg to
Columbus and they so that's how I found
out about Heidelberg mm-hmm so I went up
and played up there we were when I went
up there we were in Sports Illustrated
we were ranked number one in Sports
Illustrated for having this the
stupidest college team nickname which
was what the student princes come on the
student Prince's that would strike fear
and our opponents hearts when we would
hit the field you better be careful or
we might write a book report about you
but if you had a name like that you need
to back it up right you better so we
were oh and eight you were own eight had
the student Prince's and we actually
went to a championship game come on now
the way though it's the Ohio Athletic
Conference broken into two divisions the
blue and the red the first-place team
would play the first-place team for the
championship but ii played second third
played third all the way down so we were
the last place in our division and we
played I guess a championship game
against the last plate steamed right and
the other division and we won that game
the student Prince says yeah tonight or
not success but no the student Princeton
princes yeah and so only one how about
that yeah the Heidelberg student yeses
yes what was the so what was the uniform
I mean did you have a picture of like a
prince charming or so was that logo we
would we would run out we actually had
to have you know the books wouldn't have
like the belt around the books we would
run out of the field no they tried to
toughen it up you know it was like a
night a night oh yes it was cool it's
actually a great college and I'm glad I
went there okay yeah we want you to be
able to stroll back on campus of course
you know you need to be have your
homecoming appropriately set up for you
right there yes so um okay and now you
live in Vegas Las Vegas okay so have you
taken in the remarkable hockey team
season four Hatter's have you you guess
okay
those I got Golden Knights Golden
Knights we have I have season tickets to
all the games last year not all the
games but a handful games last year and
you're the ones who you're part of the
choreography of their of the opening
right before the pucks drop with with
all the they ask you your two cents of
your know I'm your acting they do have
people who live in Las Vegas like famous
people up on the but I didn't make the
cut you didn't make that Cano come on
now I think they know that I don't I
don't think anybody knows anybody about
me I I'm not bothered by it but it's
just interesting okay they got all these
lot like carrot top and Wayne Newton and
all that them so are you saying like you
know the Blue Man Group would get me in
group gets more other what do you mean
by up there like there's no on the big
screen at the start of the game they put
like all of the people who live in Vegas
go and go Golden Knights go Golden
Knights and I live here you know we're
on in Las Vegas Nevada Brian okay so I
think we should make this happen right
now I mean with you do you have like
again I know you're a comedian so maybe
you can improv something like you have
something that you would say to get the
crowd fired up before a game just like
like a resume tape here for to get you
on that screen
let's not win like last night no that's
probably like we have to do better we
have to improve our skills that's a go
Golden Knights yes right there that's
better than you know eating a tiger or
anything like that so tell me about this
stand-up in a way special for people
you'd put a little bit more meat on the
bones here Brian it is I'm very happy to
have the opportunity it's it's half
stand-up and half sketches it's a lot of
my older stand-up bits and then those
lead into little sketches that come out
of the the stand up and each show is
about 25 minutes one pops right into the
next and it's been a lot of fun to do
yeah I mean we just showed a clip for
the TV on the audience that spoke to me
the Lapp grill the
great guy behind the wheel at wheat
wheel of car that's right just taking
because we're all doing something other
than driving these days we're driving or
at least some of us not all of us and so
it's an actual grill on somebody's on
your lap while you're driving to work
it's a great idea have you ever tried it
it seems like did that this is something
you thought of trying no I haven't I
just thought it was a funny idea because
I'm always running late
for things and I thought what would be
the absolute worst product but you could
have out there which is flipping
flapjacks on your lap okay hot stuff on
your lap while you're driving at 70
miles an hour to work right so that's
one of the sketches that's fantastic
season one is available for streaming on
December 24th on Netflix at Brian Regan
comic we can be followed on Twitter and
then you got another Netflix special in
in the queue for next year as well right
yeah we're looking to do another just
regular stand-up special they we're
gonna do it next year but because of
this we're pushing that a little bit
it'll be probably the following year
okay
well fantastic yeah thank you we you bet
thanks for coming on here absolutely
rich I'm back any time you want thank
you because you live you live in Vegas
um you must spend a lot of time here in
Los Angeles I I love coming out here
it's a hop skip and a jump okay
fantastic well thanks for coming on
brother thank you rich you've got Brian
Regan checkout Netflix's stand-up in a
way premiering worldwide on Christmas
Eve the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience